cinq morts huit blessés huit disparus
voilà le bilan de l'explosion d'un
immeuble à massy dans l'essonne les
pompiers toujours sur place pour tenter
de retrouver des survivants
la logique de l'embargo c'est le sens de
la visite de françois mitterrand dans le
golfe
au plan diplomatique comme au plan
militaire séance historique au reichstag
où les six cent soixante trois députés
de la nouvelle allemagne se sont mises
au travail le chancelier kohl a lancé un
appel à la solidarité
une histoire d'amour par lettres
interposées joué par bruno cremer et
anouk aimée qui revient sur scène après
37 ans d'absence aller notre invité
bonsoir depuis 6 heures du matin des
pompiers des médecins et des équipes de
secours tentent désespérément de
retrouver des sucres des survivants dans
les décombres d'un immeuble de massy
dans l'essonne
ce matin trois étages du bâtiment ont
été littéralement soufflé par une très
violente explosion
cinq personnes sont mortes et huit
autres sont portées disparues
le bilan pourrait donc encore s'alourdir
anne moreau 49 personnes vivaient ici à
la place de leurs appartements une
brèche gigantesque à 6h ce matin une
explosion probablement due au gaz a
soufflé le deuxième étage de ce hlm de
massy l'immeuble s'effondre aussitôt et
matin ça fait atterrir devant la salle à
manger
on a ri sortais mon chien dans le square
où il a reçu des tonnes du lte et qui
lui ont fourni la tête
j'ai eu tout en levant embrasé ça hurle
rigole stéphane une bonne hurlait la
corse n'a ouvert notre famille on pour
à accepter des blessés et puis le samu
après une installation chez nous dans
notre salle à manger pour soigner les
blessés du ch a pris ses fins même assez
grave
le plan rouge est déclenchée
immédiatement 170 pompiers secouristes
sont sur place et vaincu huit blessés
dont quatre graves dans des hôpitaux
parisiens
parmi eux deux enfants dans la matinée
pierre joxe se rend à massy déjà l'on
s'interroge sur l'origine exacte de
l'explosion n'avons détecté aucune trace
de fuite et je pense que l'année
dernière dans le cadre de la campagne
systématique de vérification des deux
ouvrages le véhicule de recharge lui qui
était passé nous n'avons rien constaté
au milieu des gravats de grue est des
pompiers dans leur progression
la plupart du temps les secouristes sont
toutefois contraints de procéder à la
main minutieusement au moindre faux
mouvement les plaques de béton en
équilibre précaire risque de s'effondrer
à nouveau sur les éventuels survivants
ce soir huit habitants probablement
ensevelies n'ont pas encore été
localisées par les sauveteurs plusieurs
personnes sont donc encore ensevelies
sous les décombres sous les décombres de
l'immeuble en billets vous êtes sur
place et les pompiers continuent bien
sûr leurs recherches
oui s'il ya encore 80 sapeurs-pompiers
qui fouillent les décombres des secours
sont placés sous la responsabilité du
colonel jean claude longeard alors
colonel parmi les six victimes qui sont
encore ensevelies sous les décombres
est ce qu'on s'est retrouvée vivante
bien pour l'instant il y a encore un peu
d'espoir vraiment
très peu effectivement il ya encore six
victimes qu'il faudrait localité le père
d'une constitution
pourquoi est ce si difficile
d'intervenir aussi bien à cause de la
structure du bâtiment
on a une
un empilage de dalles de béton qu'il
faut retirer méthodiquement et
progressivement donc c'est un travail
très long et vous privilégié l'hypothèse
de l'explosion du regard non toujours
pas
en tout genre page peux pas vous
confirmer que c'est le gaz c'est autre
chose l'explosion aurait bien eu lieu au
deuxième étage et l'immeuble
oui c'est là où on à l'impact le plus
fort et on
on estime que c'est certainement là où a
eu lieu l'explosion et vous allez
continuer à travailler toute la nuit
s'est bien passée de ce rude 7 et leurs
environs jusqu'à la fin du déblaiement
je l'aï dit tout ce qu'on peut dire ce
soir
koolance on vous retrouve bien sûr dans
l'édition de soir3 françois mitterrand
dans le golfe le président de la
république partage est aujourd'hui son
temps entre des rencontres diplomatiques
et une visite aux troupes françaises à
yang où le chef de l'état s'est d'abord
entretenu largement avec le roi fahd
deux grandes lignes pour cette journée
la présidence française aux côtés de
l'arabie saoudite et le respect de
l'embargo
joël hasard l'embargo sans faille contre
l'irak constitue une chance de résoudre
sans conflit la crise du golfe
c'était ce matin le message délivré par
le président mitterrand a vendu duplex
au large d'abu dhabi les officiers de la
frégate française ont exposé en détail
au chef suprême des armées
le fonctionnement du dispositif français
de contrôle dans le golfe l'embargo est
totalement hermétique compte assurer les
marins du duplex après vous avez jeddah
en arabie saoudite où le chef de l'état
a été accueilli par le roi fahd et par
son frère le prince héritier abdallah
bin abdulaziz
une visite qui apparaît comme une
mission de clarification dans la mesure
le président mitterrand entendait
rassurer le roi fahd sur sa conception
des régimes du golfe en effet les
vocations à new york par le chef de
l'état d'une démocratisation nécessaire
du système quotidien terne avec quelque
peu ému les monarchies arabes
l'étape de djeddah devait donc permettre
de rapprocher si besoin était les points
de vue parigi dante affirmé en tout cas
leur volonté d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
logique de l'embargo le temps fort de
cette journée c'était bien sûr la visite
du chef de l'état aux troupes françaises
ayant bout et yang où nous rejoignons
tout de suite en direct palamara
commencer par les premières images de la
visite du président de la république
dans le port saoudien
l'embout 17 heures c'est un avion civil
qui atterrit le président des sang lui
aussi en civil mais les hommes qui
l'attendent ne voient en lui que le chef
des armées ils connaissent la
constitution française est d'un bleu
françois mitterrand perçoit le climat
qui règne en bout la logique de guerre
est là dans ce lotissement de ville à
une oasis auparavant au milieu du désert
d'arabie un camp retranché aujourd'hui
après la revue des troupes le président
et l'état majeurs vont s'enfermer dans
une des villas les officiels informe sur
la situation ils sont graves et lui et
cela n'est il se détend un peu plus tard
au milieu des chefs de corps mais
interdiction d'enregistrer l'heure n'est
pas aux petites phrases
d'après lui une conversation informelle
avec quelques journalistes le président
va repartir pour paris il 18h30
il a laissé ses consignes l'armée doit
se tenir prête au chaos et les
légionnaires le savent ils avaient déjà
regagné leur caserne
avant même le départ du chef de l'état
si le chef de l'état n'a pas fait de
déclaration officielle c'est parce qu'il
a voulu mettre l'accent sur le caractère
symbolique de son geste mais c'est plus
qu'un symbole en décidant de rendre
visite aux soldats qu'il a lui même
envoyé en arabie séoudite le chef de
l'état a voulu montrer qu'il n'excluait
toujours pas l'option militaire
il a bien sûr insister auprès des
officiers sur la nature de leur mission
essentiellement défensive l'armée
française interviendra que s'il menace
nouvelle surgit je cite ces propos que
si par exemple l'arabie saoudite était
attaqué françois mitterrand a également
insisté sur la nécessité de poursuivre
d'une manière implacable l'embargo c'est
à ses yeux l'attitude la plus efficace
qui soit mais il sait que l'irak
étrangler économiquement asphyxié par le
blocus pourrait réagir violemment
c'est un cas de figure que les
occidentaux et leurs alliés arabes
retiennent mais qui sait s'ils ne
tiennent pas à pousser saddam hussein à
la faute
confidences d'un officier à l'issue de
la réunion avant 45 jours m'at-il dit il
se passera quelque chose quoi silence
merci palais justement deux informations
politiques à propos du golfe où la cote
de popularité de françois mitterrand a
fait un bond de 9 points selon un
sondage sofres à paraître demain dans le
figaro
enfin jacques chirac vient d'adresser ce
soir une lettre à françois mitterrand le
numéro un du rpr souhaite rencontrer le
chef de l'état au plus vite
il souhaite des éclaircissements sur
l'opération daguet sur la mission des
forces françaises et sur le commandement
sous lequel elle serait placée en cas de
conflit hier le président du rpr avait
indiqué qu'il avait peut être approuvé
un peu vite l'envoi de 4000 militaires
en arabie saoudite à l'étranger premier
discours officiel d'helmut kohl ce matin
et actes de naissance de la
réunification politique
les six cent soixante trois députés de
la grande allemagne se sont réunis
symboliquement reichstag de berlin
premiers mots très solennelle du
chancelier kohl l'allemagne assumera ses
responsabilités reportage de nous
oui et spéciaux pascal verre d'eau et
philippe basquin chahut cet après midi
devant le reichstag pour cette première
session du parlement de l'allemagne unie
les apprentis des lycées professionnels
de berlin réclame des crédits de
formation et des enseignants
willy brandt le père de l'ostpolitik
très applaudie repart pour bones avec
ses collègues pour poursuivre les
travaux du nouveau bundestag
la fête est finie à berlin et c'était le
mood colle ce matin qui a tenu à
rappeler l'ampleur de la tâche
ce qui était réduit à néant en quatre
décennies ne peut être rattrapé en
quelques mois la réponse aux angoisses
de ses concitoyens en substance a dit le
chancelier
soyez patients nous vous aiderons une
philosophie l'allemagne unie est notre
patrie l'europe unie notre avenir est un
programme tous azimuts reconstruire une
économie moderniser le réseau
ferroviaire routier téléphoniques mais
aussi assainir les régions polluées
améliorer la qualification des hommes
sur le plan extérieur un light motif la
coopération avec la haye et la
réconciliation avec le peuple polonais
le discours de helmut kohl à la nation
allemande et au monde peut se résumer
ainsi rassurer rassurer mais ne pas
oublier les crimes commis par le peuple
allemand
pendant ce siècle ici à l'intérieur du
reich stagne le chancelier a tenu à
réaffirmer solennellement que son peuple
ne suivrait plus le chemin du
nationalisme une responsabilité nouvelle
de mon histoire est un fardeau pour le
chancelier de l'unité allemande
l'un des premiers problèmes à résoudre
par le nouveau parlement allemand paraît
ce soir bien dérisoire mais il est en
fait très important gouvernement
parlement ou administrations bonne ou
berlin
quel capital pour les institutions
allemandes la polémique est lancée et
reportages sur place de laurent andres
allemagne capitale berlin depuis la
fondation de la république fédérale
c'était inscrit dans les textes pour
garder l'espoir et puis par refus des
tentatives soviétique d'occuper toute la
ville
c'était berlin le symbole or hier cette
fiction est devenue une réalité et un
débat parce que la république fédérale
avait déjà sa capitale or deux capitales
c'est trop et voilà comment la haute
politique se rapproche de cloche mais
d'abord donc bonne trois cent mille
habitants siège provisoire des
institutions fédérales depuis 1948
deux grands hommes beethoven l'esprit
tutélaire et conrad adenauer qui
habitait à côté d'où son choix en
arrivant au pouvoir
ici on a beaucoup investi la ville et
bourgeoise cher et les fonctionnaires
fédéraux bien payé d'autre part un
quartier gouvernemental avec
chancellerie parlement et présidence
c'est une carte de visite en or enfin on
est ici catholique et rhénan
c'est-à-dire ennemi juré des protestants
prussiens alors pas question de renoncer
dans un état fédéral nous ne voulons pas
d'une telle concentration de pouvoir
dans une seule ville
gouvernement-parlement présidence nous
n'en voulons pas enfin dernier argument
le prix du déménagement qu'on évalue ici
à des dizaines de milliards de marks
mais on ne peut pas nier non plus que
berlin est une vraie capitale
majestueuse et centraliste elle a
d'ailleurs été fait pour cela
ici il y a les monuments l'histoire la
culture les affaires 4 millions
d'habitants alors pourquoi pas le
pouvoir
les fausses nous ne voulons pas d'un
pouvoir théorique mais le gouvernement
et le parlement
les pronostics donnent actuellement
berlin gagnant mais les députés élus le
2 décembre prochain se feront un devoir
de ménager la chèvre et le chou car
comment c'est un mandat en tranchant un
conflit aussi typiquement allemand entre
rhénan et prussiens catholiques et
protestants fédéraliste et centraliste
serait le meilleur moyen de diviser ce
qui vient juste de s'unir unification
politique sans incident donc ou presque
on ne peut pas en dire autant de la
contre cérémonie organisée hier soir
dans les rues de berlin par des
mouvements anarchistes et des groupes
d'extrême gauche sont 8000 personnes
face aux forces de l'ordre la
manifestation a tourné en échauffourées
l'atelier terre des images parts
culièrement violente celle d'une
manifestation qui finit mal
ils étaient quelques 9000 hier soir à
berlin pour protester contre la
réunification de l'allemagne
anarchiste turc communiste les autres
ceux qui n'ont pas frémi il y à 11 mois
quand le mur est tombé
ce qui n'était pas de la fête la nuit du
2 octobre porte de brandebourg ben okri
deux allemagnes cerneux là et se sont
rendus sur l'alexander platz où tout
rassemblement était interdite et c'est
là que les incidents ont éclaté entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
des dizaines de policiers agressés par
des jets de pierres des vitrines brisées
des voitures incendiés par les
protestataires qui refusaient de se
disperser
au total plus de 200 blessées et de
nombreuses interpellations à peine
reconstituer la grande allemagne et déjà
contestée en france l'opposition n'y
crois pas encore le projet de loi de
regroupement des élections cantonales et
régionales est passé en première lecture
à l'assemblée nationale
tous les partis de droite l'avait
pourtant fortement rejetée mais le
projet a été adopté en pleine nuit selon
une procédure très rarement utilisée le
vote à main levée levée de boucliers ce
matin reportage mathilde pradier et
philippe chasselas l'assemblée qui veut
plus vite que son ombre
la nuit dernière à l'heure où les bancs
de l'hémicycle sont aussi peu fréquentée
que ce couloirs de l'assemblée
le président de séance le socialiste
michel cofinot a fait adopter le projet
de loi de regroupement des élections
cantonales et régionales mais à main
levée par les députés socialistes
présents la procédure est rapide et
provoque la colère de l'opposition
celle ci affirme avoir demandé un
scrutin public qui comptabilise
l'ensemble des voix des députés présents
ou absents
si cela avait été le cas le projet
n'aurait sans doute pas été adopté c'est
n'est donc pas qu'une querelle de
procédures de mode de scrutin public a
été déposée dans les temps et même s'il
n'avait pas été déposée dans les temps
jeté en séance et en tant que président
de groupe je n'ai pas besoin de demande
écrite de scrutin public il suffit que
je lève le bras en voiture le président
séance michel cofinot estime avoir le
droit de son côté selon lui aucune
demande de scrutin public n'a été
déposée sur son pupitre
feront ils ont oublié pour la cour est
enfoui en est ils ont oublié tempête
dans un verre d'eau viol de procédure le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale étaient
réunis ce soir pour résoudre la première
polémique de la rentrée parlementaire
à peine nommé louis mermaz prend le
taureau par les cornes dès aujourd'hui
les inaugurer ses fonctions de ministre
de l'agriculture en rencontrant les
producteurs de blé première rencontre et
premier débat débat assez serré avec les
professionnels et les syndicats
reportage d'agnès poligné et philippe
guinet monter sur scène louis mermaz
aurait préféré la lumière dans la salle
première acte pour le nouveau ministre
bruxelles vient de proposer de baisser
de 30 % les subventions versées aux
agriculteurs européens
une concession face aux américains dans
le cadre des négociations du gatt
l'accord général sûr le commerce et des
tarifs douaniers
en coulisses le ministre reste très
discret raymond lacombe s'est bien
gardée d'applaudir pour lui les
ministres et trop conciliant avec les
américains et la réduction des aides à
des chanteurs ne résout rien et
absolument ridicule c'est pas là dessus
que le débat doit porter le débat
essentiel qui restent dans les
négociations mondiales à ces la gestion
du marché mondial c'est éventuellement
la gestion des actions mondiaux qui nous
faut travailler ensemble entre les pays
importateurs
le ministre connie que de voir descendre
très vite dans l'arène les problèmes de
l'élevage vont ressurgir dans les débats
jeudi prochain à l'assemblée des
constructeurs sortent leurs griffes
d'autres mettre un tigre dans leur
moteur ils sont tous présents depuis le
début de l'après midi porte de
versailles pour le 71e salon de l'auto
rebaptisé mondial de l'automobile salon
sur fond de crise mais les grands
groupes ont tenté de rivaliser
d'originalité
je dis bien tenté hervé dino et christos
camillieri si l'on dissèque ce mondial
de l'automobile on constate
paradoxalement que la véritable
nouveauté de ce salon c'est la
standardisation des véhicules en basse
et moyenne gamme
les voitures se prénomme clio 205 fiesta
ou encore aurions vectra 605 r21 mais
elles se ressemblent comme deux gouttes
d'eau est incontestablement il semble
qu'actuellement les automobilistes
préfèrent les rondes
ce salon consacre surtout les monospaces
des véhicules pouvant transporter de
sept à neuf personnes alliant confort et
convivialité
cette voiture est idéal pour les virées
en groupe désormais pontiac avec son
transport et toyota avec sa praevia
concurrence directement la renault
espace
vous pouvez enfiler lanchas voile un
vélo conserver éventuellement cinq
places 6 places est l'ap
vous avez en fait tout un tas de
formules l'aménagement donc en fait je
crois qu'en fait on va intéresser tout
le monde pour ce qui est du haut de
gamme l'année 91 sera l'année de la
honda nsx sa coque en aluminium et son
moteur 6 cylindres installé
transversalement en position centrale
arrière feront rêver les spécialistes
son prix environ 500 mille francs lui
fait pâlir les ferrari qui à qualité
égale sont 20% plus cher avec la tavriya
vendu 45 mille francs les soviétiques
vise un tout autre public
mais le style vraiment trop dépouillée
de la voiture découragera plus d'un
acquéreur 6e mondial est avant tout
affaire de gros sous les constructeurs
vous offre quand même une part de rêve
avec ses prototypes qui préfigure les
voitures de demain
le plus impressionnant est
incontestablement le voyageur 3 de
chrysler dans sa version longue il
permet de transporter 8 personnes mais
il s'est également se faire tout petit
pour aborder la ville ou tout simplement
pour laisser en plan des passagers trop
ennuyeux culture les rita mitsouko
s'explique ils ne sont plus il parle
pour dire qu'ils se sont peut-être
trompés en égarant leurs fans dans des
recherches musicales trop poussé il
s'explique avant un mois de concerts à
la cigale c'est en décembre et la sortie
de leur quatrième album intitulé ray
conférence de presse parlait d'un groupe
de rock très rock michel vial et jean
jacques ladeuille quelques secondes les
rita mitsouko je pense
la régie est ce que vous pouvez prévenir
alors un petit problème je vous propose
de regarder ce reportage un petit peu
plus tard culture toujours avec l'invité
de ce journal anouk aimée anouk aimée
bonsoir
après 37 ans d'absence au théâtre vous
décidé de remonter sur les planches vous
jouer dans une pièce d'un auteur
américain avec bruno cremer le titre
love letters et c'est au théâtre de
marigny alors première question le
théâtre après 37 ans d'absence on en
convient vraiment de vous dire chapeau
j'ai pas courte et ses 37 mais si vous
me le dites ça de tête c'est est-ce que
ça a été difficile de remonter sur les
planches après de nombreuses années au
cinéma où samy 37 ans
non mais c'est grâce à l'art schmitt 1
messieurs marc schmidt qui m'a vraiment
poussé à le faire parce que je sais pas
j'ai tout à fait embarquer dans le
cinéma ou à ne rien faire voilà c'est
cela vous a pu être difficile
l'expérience de comédiens vécu 37 ans
après vous vous a plu vous a
complètement emballé vous avez renouer
avec le théâtre
on ne s'est pas tout à fait comme ça moi
vous savez c'est pas l'acteur tout ça
c'est une façon de vivre et puis voilà
maintenant je suis là et je suis je suis
contente je suis content parce que il ya
un rapport que les gens l'acceptent bien
et que ça plaît alors évidemment je suis
si heureuse de ça alors vous jouer
peut-être votre retour sur les planches
sont donc discrètement dans une pièce
qui est à la fois tendres drôles et
parfois durs on voit tout de suite en
avoir un aperçu avec un reportage de
dominique poncet et envoie à dessein que
j'ai fais de toi et moi sans maillot de
bain de winne qui est qui
deux monstres mal-être à personne voilà
un portrait de mme hesling sharpton sans
maillot de bain vous dessine vraiment
merci beaucoup pour le cactus planté
dans le petit âne j'ai aussi un tas de
cadeaux ici à l'hôpital et je dois
écrire des petits mots de remerciements
à tout le monde
je déteste l'hôpital horriblement mal à
la gorge parce qu'on va enlever les
amygdales pleins de glace à la vanille
et on doit me prendre la température à
l'autre vous joyeux noël et bonne année
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a changé d'école
cette année alors comment éduquer mais
vous jouez dans sa pièce donc love
letters comment vous ressentez cette
pièce c'est une histoire d'amour oui
c'est une histoire d'amour c'était un
homme et une femme qui s'écrivent depuis
l'âge de 8 ans jusqu'à 50 ans ou 55 ans
et il y à tous leurs rapports ce qui
peut se passer dans l'asie et il ya des
moments drôles il ya les moments tristes
il ya des moments où il se rate eu des
moments où il se rend compte c'est une
question de timing c'est c'est la vie
est ce que vous êtes rencontrés avec
bruno cremer qui est votre partenaire en
serrant qu'on pense qu'on s'est
rencontrés hier aux portes des deux
régions non mais je j'adore travailler
avec bruno c'est formidable c'est
justement c'est quelqu'un qui ait une
dimension en plus que celle d'être un
comédien il a quelque chose en plus
alors il c'est parce que j'ai une grande
générosité
alors vous savez donc à un grand
partenaire bruno krief en fait quand
même un retour discret mais bon qui va
me dit que vous avez d'autres projets
quatre heures peut-être mais celui qui
discret pourquoi tout ce que vous êtes
au petit marigny vous n'avez pas fait
énormément de cette pièce non il n'est
pas le cas de tout le monde mais c'est
bien je trouve il faut c'est je crois à
l'époque maintenant il faut faire des
choses comme ça revenir à prendre voir
si les gens aiment
j'ai passé une façon de vivre j'ai envie
de vivre comme ça si les gens aiment
c'est formidable et puis ça il ya un
grand succès c'est formidable mais il
faut pas faire pour le succès c'est bien
d'avoir du succès de ce que vous faites
mais il faut pas faire du risque tout à
fait mais vous ne m'avez pas répondu
mais d'autres grands projets de la trame
en vue on y lit à des projets oui allez
non j'ai pas de révéler ce nom il ya
déjà des projets qu'est ce que vous
pensez en ce moment de beaucoup de
comédiennes de cinéma qui monte sur les
planches
on a l'impression que c'est un peu une
épidémie non mais voici je pense pas
tellement de ces choses là je vais est
excusez moi mais je ne sais pas quoi
dire sur le port
je n'ai pas l'impression parfois que le
cinéma essaie de se racheter par les
acteurs de cinéma il sait que se
racheter nan est le montant du plan
je ne sais pas pour elle je leur demande
et pour moi non je ne sais pas ce
qu'elles ont envie de faire ça peut-être
qu'elles n'ont pas les rôles qui arrive
qu'elles veulent au cinéma alors elles
peuvent peut-être les avoirs au théâtre
il est aussi ce qui n'est pas votre cas
anouk aimée je vous remercie je rappelle
que vous jouez dans love letters depuis
le 21 septembre et jusqu'à quelle date
je ne sais pas nous sommes là pour trois
mois peut être plus sûr non plus c'est
au petit marigny avec bruno cremer tout
de suite le rappel des grands titres de
l'information de la journée
explosion probablement due au gaz dans
un immeuble à massy dans l'essonne bilan
tragique cinq morts huit blessés et huit
disparus
sur place les sauveteurs vont poursuivre
leurs recherches dans les décombres
pendant toute la nuit
françois mitterrand rend visite au roi
fahd et aux militaires français dans le
golfe principal message politique sur la
crise l'embargo tout l'embargo rien que
l'embargo
séance qu'historique du parlement
allemand réunifiée au rail ce tag dans
un discours-programme le chancelier kohl
a affirmé que l'allemagne n'oubliera pas
sa responsabilité dans le génocide juif
ne dites plus salon de l'auto dit
mondial de l'automobile un changement de
nom qui ne change rien à l'ambiance de
crise qui frappe le secteur - 11 % sur
les ventes de voitures en septembre
cette édition est maintenant terminée le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
c'est soir 3 présenté par marc hautement
à 22h45
avant cela une soirée cinéma et polar
sur la chaîne avec à 20h35 premier film
de la dernière séance la sphère al
capone et à 23h05 un film d'alfred
hitchcock mais qui a tué harry tout de
suite la météo complète de florence
klein à demain 19h bonsoir
demain